what did the doctors say exactly that's
probably what the troubles been about
getting pregnant the thing is I mean you
know I've been really happy with Ray not
turns out there was a reason there was a
reason I couldn't conceive oh you're
lucky Laura I don't think you can call
yourself a woman until you're a mother
where the joke is all my life I could do
everything I mean I could do anything
really except the one thing I wanted yes
that's all well at least now they'll be
able to deal with it that's right that's
what they're doing that's right hmm I'm
not worried well it's going to worrying
no it's not in your hands that's it it's
in the hands of some physician I've
never even met some surgeon who probably
drinks more martinis than rayon kitties
I mean it cause I'm worried about Ray
come here I'm doing fine really
I know where you are I'm more worried
about ring anything is not good with
this stuff
forget about him mm-hmm just forget
about right
you're sweet
[Music]